en novembre dernier lors des nrj music
awards nikos aliagas avait fait une
boulette en prenant son mal le nom de la
chanteuse
ayhan nakamura les langues qui fait bien
cinq mois après les faits elle a
toujours l'air en colère contre
l'animateur de tf1 on vous résume tout
ça et vous nous direz si vous êtes team
aya nakamura ou team nikos je rappelle
que voilà j'aime beaucoup les deux mais
on ne touche pas à aillas n'a qu'à moi
regarder c'est ce qu'on appelle avoir la
rancune tenace
voilà cinq mois que la chanteuse diana
qu'amour à étaient invités des nrj music
awards de tf1 à l'époque nikos aliagas
avait eu la maladresse des corps chez
son nom en l'appelant sur la scène de
l'émission voici diaka nakamura une
petite erreur que la jeune femme avait
pris très à coeur suite à la cérémonie
elle s'était empressé de tweets et un
message pour le moins explicite on
invite à les gens quand on n'arrive pas
à dire son nom correctement mais si on
pouvait imaginer que depuis le temps la
chanteuse avait passé l'épongé
on découvre dans une interview à télé 7
jours qu'il n'en est rien il aurait pu
au moins me plaît on m'avait dit de lui
passer un coup de fil après mon message
sur twitter où je remettais un peu les
choses au point
mais je pense que c'est plutôt à lui de
faire un geste je suis cash avant de
conclure
j'attends son appel et vous vous êtes
plutôt team nikos outils maya nakamura
on se rappelle tous de cette affaire
toutefois s'il vous plaît vous êtes plus
team ico sous steam alliant nakamura
alors vous à ben voilà oui ah oui ah oui
à rien n'à qu'à moi il ya d'autres
jeunes écoutent il ya des pots cassés
pour toi tu étais qu'est ce que tu fais
là il va écouter après tu vas te faire
une idée
j'aime beaucoup négoce mais je comprends
aya nakamura parce que lorsqu'on vient
est dans une émission et conséquence son
nom je comprends qu'on pète avant une
petite susceptibilités sur son nom je
lui accorde moi j'essaie pourtant j'aime
beaucoup me courent m'appeler cyril
ramdoo la maison avec marc godard cyril
hanouna
non mais ça en fait on voit là on perd
vers des niveaux de ces absurdités
complet yacaman huras est passé par un
créateur japonais ça n'a rien à voir
oui jean michel maire oui on dîne dans
leurs portes dans le projet alors déjà
on va reprendre le plus tôt de pitié
dans le sujet on dit qu'il est
rancunière elle pas en cuir elle a un
melon de 6éme ainsi pourquoi vous mais
parce que ça vous plaît pas mais c'est
pas parlé je n'ai pas de chocolat
et le lendemain pour assumer technique
au self un site comptant on n'abîme pas
les gens qu'on ne connaît pas son nom et
papa font c'est faux
voilà comprimé très bien compris
comprend rien à rien elle a devancé 28
ans font c'est donc elle la suit pas la
finlande 0 qui avait des photographes
elle ne dit pas de bêtise il ya plein de
faux dans les tweets va pas écrire comme
un bon annoncé qu'il allait abréger on
en parle les gens reconnaît passionnant
bah moi je fais plein de fois dans les
fautes d'orthographe aussi ces nouvelles
arrivent vite c'est ce que vous dites
encore d'autres leçons qu'on en arrive
au pays moi je trouve moi franchement
moi j'adore aya nakamura l'est toujours
nuit ici alors j'ai dit allez allez vous
d'y aller elle est d'une grande humilité
a fait un don justal a été vexé et je
l'appelle c'est pas compliqué de retenir
il ya des jours où l'attendent en
afrique a été le héros paul la donnée
est venu faire sa fille personnel ces
droits que les gens attendaient 2,3 en
aéroport oui monsieur
bon voilà on peut effectivement se
tromper mais c'est vrai que un petit
coup de fil
et voilà je suis désolé ça s'arrête
camélée chaudat pour le cousin n'a fait
qu'envenimer les choses est très dommage
parce que on peut être vexé quand on se
fait appeler d'un être qui a été dit ah
ok mais alors alors je vous dirai après
nikos peut-être qu'il va l'appeler fête
qui s'est pas rendu compte du voile a eu
du mal à quelqu'un je pense que c'est
trop tard et m'a pas la paix maintenant
pour lui c'est passé son temps mais vous
vous êtes si malin nakamura je suis dit
maya nakamura parce que il ya des
personnes plus sensibles que d'autres et
je pense qu'à mon avis bas finalement
elle l'a très mal vécu et je pense quand
on est un grand cahier
comme nikos il n'y a pas beaucoup de
nouveaux chanteurs y en a pas des
centaines jeunes gabonais on peut on
peut retenir
mettez vous à la place diana cas moi je
vous dis elle dit à toute sa famille je
vais faire les nrj music awards
vous croyez quoi est il à nikos est allé
tout dessus on va recevoir cabale
manouane ya toute sa famille qui regarde
mon frère sans rigoler il ya deux
derniers tickets skill de quoi ils vont
lui parler après la cérémonie il nous
parlait que de ça à ta vu nico sais même
pas comment tu t'appelles erreur a pris
la cause immédiatement
quant à lui seul aurait pu de panissars
hier il a retenu l'an dernier
nous n'avons ni qu'elle cartonne à
kaboul non